i've always got to go that way though
oh anyway oh anyway right
go on oh look yay
well so far it looks quite simple
so you just move this across okay
all right okay
so what do what did i what does i can't
if i join these two
do i want to use that one
uh
okay
um
it's
already i'm only a few seconds in and
it's this could be a huge draw my time
so don't i'm not getting this pretty
this is the type of thing that i will
get obsessive about
let me see
yes
it's okay i must say that i don't find
it terribly engaging but um i think
after another two or three games i'd be
thoroughly bored but
not as exciting as chemistry
right i get bored of this now that's
going to do it really yeah already yeah
i'm not intrigued it doesn't doesn't do
it for me now
i i don't like doing i like this thing i
like to have things to be slow and i
like to think about something
no i know but i know i it just does
nothing for me that i thought when you
explained it to me first as i said 2048
i had some sort of vision of a
post-apocalyptic you know game where you
mutilate everything i didn't realize it
was powers of two so um
yeah interesting do you play games no
i i delete games from my computer
this this type of gadgetry i really hate
it
so think about each move i
i don't even want to i just don't want
to waste my thoughts on it you know it
just does turns me off
right
i do my work and i do it i like to think
about physics and maths and
you know
like
at a
research level and doing all that and i
like it i like all that but all these
these computer games
i just think computer games are just
they annoy me they've always annoyed me
how do you unwind then if you don't use
computer games like this like what do
you normally do to do physics
unfortunately
calculate
i love calculating
what i love doing is just sitting down
doing some calculations i'm not showing
you that
you're not showing me that don't show it
to anyone
not until it's published anyway
there were three things i waffle on
about physics music and my kids and they
would love this my daughters would
absolutely love this and this is great
it gets them to to think about powers of
two you get to think about powers or two
you're thinking about binary you're
pretty well a computer scientist there
and then so yeah great
so 3328.
a bit better than phil moriarty
but he's a physicist
it's just boring i mean i i i
i spent all my day in front of a t of a
computer screen
so the last thing i want to do i i
that's not quite true occasionally
over a cup of coffee if i want to break
i don't mind playing computer chairs
but that's something i'm familiar with
would your wife like yeah my wife would
like it yeah she'd love
it would she like it is she better at
math than you
she's an accountant
she's very proud of us yeah
she's fair at doing sums
five thousand two hundred and forty
game two
are you pleased yeah
if you give me a cricket ball go to the
net i'd be very happy to play a game but
this is just
yeah
i like that but um
yeah it could be very addictive very
very quickly it's like sudoku in it if
you have one of these like a job which
doesn't require to think that way during
the day
you do this at home because you know
just to say you you're exercising your
brain that way but if i get home i'm to
think about all this you know maths all
day
you want to just you say you just want
to watch breaking bad
i imagined you having a bit of an
addictive personality and maybe getting
quite into this sort of thing no